Now in adapting our form DB
code to use a real database,
you might have written something
that looks a lot like this.
In the get all posts function, you
connect to a database, make a cursor,
execute a SELECT statement,
format the results appropriately,
close the connection return the posts.
But then to add a post,
connect to the database, make a cursor.
Execute an INSERT that
substitutes in the post content,
commit that to the database and close.
Now, this looks good,
but it isn't quite.
If you're writing a bunch
of different forum app.
Are there any posts that don't
seem to work quite right?
Say what?
Wait a minute.
That looked like a perfectly good post.
Why are we getting this
weird error from it?
Let's go back to our terminal.
Oh, look at this.
We have a trace back from python.
It says programming error.
Syntax error at or near t.
And there's out INSERT statement VALUES.
I can't find a problem.
Let's look back at the code.
So, here's where the post content,
gets sent to the database.
It just gets added into a SQL statement.
Inside single quotes.
Because, we put SQL strings
inside single quotes.
But the database, sees the quote from
the post, and it thinks that's the end
of a string, and that t is
something it doesn't understand.
By the way,
if your code didn't have this bug,
congratulations, that's awesome.
But stay tuned, because there's more
to this bug than might first appear.
Despite the fact that we had a little
problem, we can still post things.
As long as they don't have
single quotes in them.
But here's something to try.
Single quote.
Close param.
Semi colon.
Don't retype this from what I'm saying.
Copy it from the instructor notes,
and put them into your forum.
Delete from posts.
Semi colon.
Double dash.
Post this.
Wait, all, all of our posts are gone.
I thought we had a database here.
Hey, wait a minute.
I thought I saw this one
on the webcomic XKCD.
What we have here is a security hole
called an SQL injection attack.
Some of the post's text is being
treated as a database command,
namely delete from posts.
Which as it happens, means delete
every row from the posts table.
Well, that stinks.
All those brilliant test
posts we wrote are gone, and
we have a famous security
bug in our code.
How are we going to fix this?
Well, we might not be able to get
all those great posts back, but
we should be able to at least
keep it from happening again.